an individual has lost the ability to
activate b cells and mount a humeral
immune response
part a propose one direct consequence of
the loss of b cell activity on the
individual's humeral immune response to
the initial exposure to a bacterial
pathogen so just as a reminder what b
cells are and what a humeral immune
response are hemohumeral immune response
is one that involves antibodies and b
cells are the ones that will recognize
an antigen something that the body
doesn't want in its body and then in
response to that those antigens it will
produce it'll one it'll proliferate
it'll differentiate into plasma cells
that produce antibodies which are
essentially these macromolecules that
tag the antigens for cleanup and then it
can differentiate into memory b cells so
that next time when those that same
antigen shows up it can mount a faster
response so part a
propose one direct consequence of the
loss of b-cell activity on the
individual's humeral immune response to
the initial exposure to a bacterial
pathogen so there won't be a humeral
response so i could say
no
no antibodies
bodies
will
be
produced
so no humoral immune response so
there
will
be
no
humoral immune response humeral
immune
response
to the initial exposure
to
initial
exposure so you're not going to have any
tagging of these antigens that they're
going to be cleaned up by other by other
immune cells none of that's going to
happen
part b
propose one direct consequence of the
loss of b-cell activity on the speed of
the individual's humeral immune response
to a second exposure to the bacterial
pathogen well you have no memory b cells
no
memory b cells
and no antibodies
antibodies
specific or i could say for
second exposure to pathogen for second
exposure
to
pathogen
so no humeral response
so
no
humoral
response
and overall immune response will be
slower the whole point of b cells and
the antibodies is that the second time
it shows around it gets tagged very
quickly it gets recognized very quickly
and then the immune system can respond
well now you're not going to have that
you're not going to have this in the
secondary exposure that quick
recognition of the antigen so you're not
going to have humeral response and you
could say overall
overall
immune response
immune response will be slower immune
response is going to be slower and less
effective
slower and less
all right let's think about part c
describe one characteristic of the
individual's immune response to the
bacterial pathogen that is not affected
by the loss of b cells well the b cells
are all about the humeral immune
response it's about it's about tagging
things with antibodies having the memory
b cells around so that the next time you
get the the the pathogen the second
exposure you have a quicker response but
it's not the only part of our immune
system your immune system has still many
facets to it one you're still going to
have the cell mediated immune response
still
have
cell
mediated
immune response
immune
response
and these are things like
these are things like phagocytes that
will go and engulf that will engulf the
pathogens
phagocytes
phagocytes you have you have t cells
that can recognize the antigen and
similarly try to go about destroying the
antigen so you still have the cell in
cell mediated immune response you also
have
things like the skin things that just
block
things that block pathogens from
entering your body and that's considered
part of your immune system
still
still have
skin
protection and you can go into more
detail but these are still the types of
things that the body has even if it lost
its b cell capability in order to
prevent pathogens from entering in the
case of skin and also still once the
pathogens get in to still recognize them
and engulf them or destroy them in some
way